nous accueillons stefan esser
c'est pas les seuls bons soirs bon choix
vous êtes l'auteur du phénomène
littéraire de ces deux dernières années
votre livre indignez vous s'est vendu à
4 millions d'exemplaires dans le monde
et c'est pas fini c'est vrai que c'est
arrivé au stade où finissez par être
vous même indignée du succès de votre
livre
absolument en tous les cas bravo hein
stéphane hessel rebond soir alors ses 94
ans et vous battez ce soir le record de
l'invité le plus âgé de l'émission bravo
bravo
c'est un record qui était détenu jusque
là par edgar morin qui est votre ami oui
et michel galabru voilà un big up
[Applaudissements]
alors stéphane nous allons commencer par
parler de votre vie mais vu votre âge je
crois qu'on va faire un petit résumé
vous m'en voulez pas oui oh là soyez
bref alors vous êtes né à berlin le 20
octobre 1917 père juif homme de lettres
qui traduira proust et nabokov proche du
champ de man ray mère protestante
luthérienne issu d'une famille de
banquiers en très antisémite mais qui
ont reconnu que mon père bien que juive
était un excellent mari pour ses valeurs
alors votre maire partagera sa vie entre
votre père est l'écrivain pierre henri
roché dont le roman jules et jim sera
portée à l'écran par françois truffaut
mais oui le petit garçon que j'étais n'a
rien compris à tout ce qui se passait
j'avais 3 ans 1 mais par la suite le
fait d'avoir une mère qui soit une
personnalité très forte très libre très
moderne a joué naturellement un rôle
considère un sua roma formation au
rocher aussi a joué un rôle considérable
dans votre vie baisse de 2 deuxième père
il vous permettra de fréquenter
l'intelligentzia de l'époque c'était un
proche de guillaume apollinaire par
exemple qui pour moi reste le poète mais
bon poète favori bac à 15 ans ensuite de
brillantes études supérieures fait
normale sup en 1939 c'est l'armée vous
est fait prisonnier et vous vous évader
pour rejoindre de gaulle à londres en
1941 vous dites c'est un engagement qui
dépasse la morale classique vous méfier
de la la moraline en fait de nietzsche
et qui fait d'être différence entre ce
qui est légal et ce qui est légitime et
quelquefois ce qui est légal n'est pas
léger bravo j'adore alors ensuite bon
bah c'est la résistance vous êtes arrêté
en 1944 vous êtes déporté à buchenwald
où vous échapperait à la pendaison à un
croc de boucher grâce à une substitution
d'identité avec un détenu mort du typhus
un dénommé boitel michel bois thiel qui
reste une un poids sur ma conscience il
est mort et grâce à sa mort j'ai survécu
faut porter alors ensuite j'ai été
envoyé à doha où les nazis fabriquées
leur fameuse fusée qui devait détruire
londres les v1 et v2 vous évader et vous
rejoignez l'armée américaine là vous
entrez dans la diplomatie et en 1946 est
à new york où vous assistez à la
rédaction de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme aux nations unies
et si sur les valeurs de ce texte sur
celle du conseil national de la
résistance que vous fondre et vos
engagements d'après guerre et qui
inspireront votre incroyable best-seller
indignez-vous traduit en 33 langues
vendu à 4 millions d'exemplaires dans le
monde vous êtes quand même le français
qui a vendu le plus de livres au monde
en 2011 quand même ben voilà mieux que
marc levy c'est le fait que nous soyons
tombés juste nous avons parlé
d'indignation à un monde il n'était pas
satisfait de la manière dont ils étaient
conduits et qui avait donc des raisons
de dire on veut pas de ça au sein d'ibm
alors vous dites l'indignation est le
ferment de l'esprit de résistance je
pense que le mot résistance est un mot
précieux qui signifie qu on ne peut pas
accepter le monde tel qu'il est il y a
toujours quelque chose d'inacceptable et
qui mérite qu'on se manifeste qu'on
s'indigne
ouais il faut dire aux gens de résister
parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens résistent
peu sauf quand il faut prendre du
dessert quoi en général
alors grâce à vous a été instauré le
samedi 15 octobre dernier la journée
mondiale des indignés
enfin faut quand même relativiser parce
que c'est également la journée mondiale
du lavage de mains vous saviez ça
commençons par vous l'avait dépeint et
ensuite on s'indignera ce qui ne va pas
dans la boue c'est véridique alors
qu'est-ce qui vous indigne en ce moment
où ses fans la façon dont nous avons
traité en france les immigrés quand on
essaye de faire le départ entre ceux qui
seraient de vrais bons français et puis
s'il rêve pas de vraiment bon français
mais qu'il faut quand même accepté chez
nous alors c'est la fin est-ce que les
gens qui disent par contre au lieu de
dire en revanche c'est ce que ça vous
indigne ça et pas vraiment mais vous
avez raison de nous mettre sur cette
voie la façon dont on parle la façon
dont on s'exprime surtout quand on
occupe une fonction importante au
gouvernement faut faire attention casse
toi pauvre con par exemple bah oui
j'étais un bon exemple est ce que vous
êtes indignés par le livre de goldnadel
qui vous accusent d'avoir enjolivé votre
passé de résistant ah non mais je trouve
heureux d'avoir quelqu'un qui me
traitent de vieillards indique que ça ça
me fait plaisir quand il s'agit de
quelqu'un pour lequel je ne peut avoir
aucune aucun respect parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui dit n'importe quoi il va
pas de main morte il dit vous avez
exagéré votre participation à la
rédaction de la déclaration universelle
des droits de l'homme de l'onu et puis
ce qui les énerve le plus en fait c'est
que vous focalisez souvent vos critiques
contre l'état d'israël ça il ne supporte
pas mais oui mais je le comprends je
sais que les israéliens sont très
sensibles il se considère comme la seule
démocratie du proche orient alors qu'ils
ne sont ni démocrates ni respectueux du
droit international on ne peut pas
accepter que les palestiniens soient
traités comme ils l'ont été tout au long
de ces quarante dernières années et
notamment à gaza lorsque c'est à preuve
opération plomb durci a été menée par le
gouvernement il fallait bien ça je ne
lui pardonne pas alors goldnadel dit en
parlant de vous s'imaginent que vous le
savez stéphane hessel c'est l'abbé
pierre - la soutane ah mais oui mais il
me manque en effet une soutane si vous
en avez
[Applaudissements]
alors tes fans cette semaine est sorti
votre nouveau livre publié chez don
quichotte et intitulé de rescapés et
l'exil est alors le rescapé évidemment
c'est vous et l'exil et c'est elias
sanbar représentant de la palestine à
l'unesco alors vous dialoguez tous les
deux sur israël et la palestine vous
poser la question est ce que c'était
vraiment là on palestine qu'il fallait
installer ce foyer national c'était un
effet une question qu'on pouvait se
poser nous savions qu'il y avait des
arabes et des chrétiens d'ailleurs et
des juifs déjà qu'ils vivaient la
valette il donnait shechter la aux juifs
qui sortait de l'horreur de la shoah et
bien finalement j'ai pensé qu'on a bien
fait je pense que jérusalem pour eux est
un endroit qui n'a pas de comparaison le
dossier madagascar il y avait des idées
mais aucune ne valait ce retour des
juifs dans une terre qui leur était
tellement cher vous dis que plus
dramatique c'est qu'à l'époque ne
pensions pas qu'il existait un peuple
palestinien nous pensions qu'il y avait
des arabes et que ces arabes disposer
d'un vaste territoire vous avez pris
conscience en fait de l'existence du
peuple palestinien en 1967 c'est ça à
partir du moment où israël gagnant une
guerre et au lieu d'en tirer une
conséquence en dix ans maintenant notre
sécurité a assuré
nous allons travailler avec nos voisins
et leur donner un état ils ont au
contraire occupé d'abord colonisé
ensuite oui vous dites on a vraiment
pris conscience qu'il existait un peuple
palestinien qu'il avait une patrie la
palestine où il vivait depuis fort
longtemps et d'où ils avaient été
chassés par une armée moderne et
violente exactement alors finalement ce
sont la guerre et le terrorisme qui vous
ont fait prendre conscience de la
réalité palestinienne d'une certaine
façon le peuple israélien est un peuple
pour lequel j'ai beaucoup d'affection
mais qu'ils se soient laissés dirigés
par des gouvernements
fasciste je le dis tout clairement et
qui font de l'occupation et de la
colonisation
ça me révolte à gaza il n'y avait déjà
plus de colons israéliens ils s'en
étaient retirés mais là dessus il ya eu
un mouvement hamas violent je ne
reconnais violent agressive qui a envoyé
des roquettes mais au lieu d'essayer de
faire la paix avec lui on l'a envahie
avec une opération qu'on a appelée plomb
durci et qui a fait plus de 1400
victimes en l'espace de trois semaines
vous dit en parlant des palestiniens la
violence est totalement légitime quand
le faible n'a pas d'autre moyen de
résister à l'oppression et vous comparez
en fait la violence des des palestiniens
à celle des résistants français contre
les nazis il n'y a rien eu au monde de
plus épouvantable que ce que nous
appelons la shoah c'est à dire la façon
dont les juifs d'europe ont été
exterminés par les nazis il reste que
lorsque une pays un gouvernement se
comporte vis à vis de ses voisins d'une
façon brutale d'une façon sans aucun
respect pour leurs droits fondamentaux
eh bien on a affaire à quelque chose qui
nous rappellent la façon dont nous
français avons été traités par nos
envahisseurs allemands ouais donc la
violence légitime quand il ya violence
il faut répondre alors il faut essayer
dé répondre par anne non violence ni un
exemple admirable nous est donné sept
ans y sommes
shoji la grande birmane prix nobel
nos violent de bout en bout pas une
action violente et maintenant elle finit
par avoir son mot à dire pour l'avenir
de son pays gandhi a libéré langue sans
violence exactement alors est ce que
pour finir cette interview vous pourriez
nous dire un petit poème aux mets
volontiers un petit apollinaire par
exemple un peu court quand je commence à
réciter mes enfants me disent papa on
veut bien poèmes et course
alors je vous propose celui qu'il
appelait l'automne dans le brouillard
s'en vont un paysan khâgneux et son
boeuf lentement dans le brouillard
d'automne qui cache les hameaux pauvres
et bergonié et ce en allant là-bas de
paysans chantonne une chanson d'amour et
d'infidélité qui parle d'une bande et
d'un coeur que l'on brise à l'automne
l'otan a fait mourir l'été dans le
brouillard s'en vont de silhouettes
grises hu bravo caméra
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
lean landi tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou